[Música]
bom vou começar com uma palestra uma
pergunta pra vocês mas antes dessa
pergunta eu queria que vocês pensar
assim uma coisa uma coisa importante que
vocês fizeram hoje uma coisa que
deixaram vocês gratos uma coisa legal
pode ser qualquer coisa ea primeira
coisa que vem à cabeça
pensaram agora eu queria que alguém
levantasse a mão quem pensou no que eu
vou falar levantasse a mão se vocês
pensaram que você tiver a oportunidade
no banheiro que esse banheiro estava
dentro do lugar que vocês estavam que
quando vocês chegaram nesse banheiros
encontrar um vaso com água limpa
vocês usaram dando a descarga ea água
ficou limpa de novo você tiver a
oportunidade de se lavar de lavar a mão
de tomar um banho e beber uma água e
essa água segura vocês confiaram na água
que receberam alguém pensou alguma coisa
assim ninguém
a gente não pensa mesmo assim como a
gente não pensa quando a gente respira
mas talvez se você tivesse que sair de
casa
na chuva ou no sol pra ir pra esse
banheiro ou beber água nesse lugar aí ou
para essas crianças
talvez vocês 10 em valor para essa coisa
simples que a gente não deu valor e que
vocês não pensaram que a diferença entre
nós e essas pessoas que passou já aí é o
saneamento básico eo lance do saneamento
básico é que ele é básico e não será
muito complementaram os elementos
supérfluos elemento ótico é fundamental
para a nossa sobrevivência do nosso
estilo de vida
quando a gente vê essas imagens que eu
tô passando a gente sente chocado mas
pode ter certeza que você tivesse lá o
choque seria muito maior
pensa naquele dia que vocês foram para
um lugar incrível uma cachoeira um pôr
do sol um lugar sensacional você bater
uma foto
vocês foram mostrar essa foto para
alguém se a pessoa que viu essa foto
sentiu a mesma emoção que vocês tiveram
quando se bater uma foto
nunca é igual né e não é igual mesmo e
não foi igual pra mim eu sou engenheiro
civil
eu como todos nós foi bombardeado pela
informação da falta de saneamento básico
no brasil e foi há dois anos atrás
quando meu amigo henrique mazzei me
chamou pra construir uma casa de
emergência com a ong teto uma casa como
essa aqui que é uma casa muito simples
que nem banheiro tem que eu fui eu fui
designado por uma comunidade chamada
vila beira mar no rio de janeiro duque
de caxias e eu inocente quando eu vivi
lá beiramar falei dei sorte para o seu
lugar mais maneiro deve ser um
lugarzinho beira-mar vou ter 11 uma
brisa para respirar vai ser um lugar
legal mas não foram não foi uma área
brisa que eu encontrei lá que encontrei
lá foi um cenário parecido com esse
o esgoto 100 das casas dava pra perceber
quando as pessoas puxar uma descarga o
esgoto correndo pelo meio das pessoas
lixo pra todo lado muita doença porcos
sendo criado no meio das pessoas
as crianças nessas comunidades elas
ficam doentes o tempo todo
as crianças têm diarreia as mães têm
dificuldade de trabalhar porque tem que
ficar em casa cuidando dessas crianças e
eu fiquei muito chocado com essa
situação
fiquei realmente um pensamento quase
obsessivo e daí fui pesquisar um pouco e
quando fui pesquisar um pouco e me
deparei com uma estatística assustadora
no brasil só 51% do nosso esgoto é
coletado tratado só 22%
apesar de a gente ser a nona economia do
mundo a gente ocupa uma posição de
saneamento básico de número 112 os 33
primeiros países estão empatados em
primeiro lugar porque já resolveram já
universalizar o saneamento básico
a organização mundial da saúde fala que
para cada real gasto em saneamento
básico a gente economiza 4 em saúde ao
longo do tempo
o instituto trata brasil fez uma conta
que o brasil lucraria em dinheiro um
trilhão de reais em 20 anos se a gente
decidisse simplesmente investir designar
o nosso dinheiro pra universalizar o
saneamento básico
já sabendo disso eu resolvi que não
podia mais ficar simplesmente
telespectador é o espectador dessa
situação eu tinha que fazer alguma coisa
mas fazer o quê
o que eu posso fazer diante de um
problema tão grande que afinal de contas
não tem nada a ver com isso não é minha
responsabilidade já pagam mais impostos
que eu posso fazer mas eu decidi
caminhar e decidiu caminhar sem saber
muito bem o caminho nem onde eu ia
chegar
comecei a falar com as pessoas eu queria
dar meu testemunho de como é
impressionante quando a gente se move
por uma causa dessas como as portas se
abrem as pessoas se abre e as
oportunidades aparecem porque em pouco
tempo poucos meses eu fui convidado para
participar da universalização do
saneamento básico numa comunidade é que
ficava do lado do instituto chega grajaú
pelo seu presidente roberto leves no
trecho da granja um é uma ong que cuida
de crianças há 25 anos na zona sul de
são paulo e ele e ele me apresentou por
guilherme castanha que é um papa da
permacultura especializado em ciclos de
água e aí outras pessoas incríveis se
juntarem a gente teve uma idéia coletiva
porque a gente não faz nada sozinho
essa ideia que a gente construiu virou
um projeto esse projeto virou uma ong
que se chama de orçamento que hoje eu
tenho a responsabilidade ea honra de
presidir o nosso carro chefe nosso
primeiro passo é a construção de
pequenas biodigestores como esse
esse biodigestor ele atendia três
famílias e trata o esgoto dessas
famílias dessas famílias ele é feito com
materiais que você pode encontrar em
qualquer lugar e é muito mais barato que
o sistema convencional rápido e fácil de
fazer e quem constrói e se esse sistema
na comunidade são pessoas da própria
comunidade
assim além de uma renda construindo isso
eles vão ter um protagonismo de
transformar a face mais dura da
realidade que eles vivem hoje é esse
bicho gestor também é lei produz um
biogás que hoje é muito importante para
as pessoas que têm dificuldade tem não
tem dinheiro pra comprar gás hoje 25 por
cento de toda a energia consumida pelas
famílias do brasil
é é a linha ou madeira queimada e fogões
improvisados em todos os barracos
queimar a madeira dentro desses barracos
é tão é tão a cancerígeno quanto fumar
cigarro né então além de uma questão
financeira você tem essa questão de você
ter esse benefício para as famílias e
tem uma questão ambiental muito
importante ele esse biogás é um gaz
metan que normalmente ele já é produzido
pelo esgoto em qualquer situação que
esgotou se encontram nas fossas na
condução de esgoto mesmo no sistema
convencional de tratamento ele vai para
a atmosfera eo metano é muito pior que o
co2 prefeito global do aquecimento
global
então a gente que estava produzindo uma
solução por uma questão social da
comunidade
de repente se deu conta que a gente
estava contribuindo para o aquecimento
global estava ajudando caras muito
distantes da gente como esse cara aqui ó
que está longe da gente e está sofrendo
acontecimento global voltando para 78%
de esgoto que não é tratado no brasil
você pra cada biodigestor 33 famílias
vão deixar de contribuir com esse
conhece com essa estatística de da falta
de saneamento básico do do esgoto nos
nossos rios
os nossos rios é praias praias incríveis
que o pinheiros você tem praia do
flamengo baía de guanabara totalmente
poluído sem chance acostumou
são lugares totalmente poluída sem
remédio novamente poluídos mas eles não
são um esgoto é composto basicamente por
matéria orgânica e quando a gente fizer
a nossa lição de casa e tratar o esgoto
dessa desses lugares naturalmente num
prazo muito curto de tempo o problema
vai ser resolvido e essa poluição vai
desaparecer naturalmente
então eu queria concluir dizendo que o
ensinamento ele não vai resolver o
problema do saneamento básico sozinho
mas a gente não vai desistir até que
esse problema não vai parar até que esse
problema seja resolvido e também a gente
vai começar pelas pessoas que mais
necessitam e para aquelas que estão no
fim da fila
pra ter esse problema resolvido e eu
queria dizer que nós como pessoas da
comunidade em geral
a gente não pode esperar do governo
resolver nossos problemas
os nossos governantes sempre são pessoas
conservadoras pelo pela posição que eles
ocupam e as grandes transformações
sociais ao longo da história sempre
foram resolvidas pelas próprias pessoas
então eu queria que vocês incra já sem e
soubesse do poder da força que a gente
tem de transformar a realidade e se
juntassem a causas como essa pode ser o
funcionamento a causa que vocês
realmente incomodam para transformar o
nosso país é o nosso mundo é isso
obrigado
[Aplausos]